how confident are you about getting a
deal at cop i think the right thing
right now is to focus on
the last days of this and really focus
people's minds we've made great progress
when we started our process as
presidency of cop
something like a third of the global
economy was covered by net zero
commitments it's now um much much higher
than that um close to
90 percent we've seen uh commitments uh
this week and last week on coal
deforestation methane but ultimately
we've got to make sure you've got the
combination of two particular elements
one the the commitments to cut emissions
the nationally determined contributions
but also the finance the international
climate finance we doubled our
commitment to make sure that the poorest
most vulnerable countries are locked in
and have got the wherewithal the
technology the know-how to meet their
obligations as well okay um i do want to
talk about sleaze of course but before
that um
um zagari ratcliffe her poor husband is
outside your old office and he's been
there for 17 days i spoke to him
yesterday i mean he's not a well man in
that his brain is working slower he's
not eaten for 17 days he needs his wife
home what are you doing
well look as you'll know when during my
period as foreign secretary um first of
all i've met with richard a number of
times i also should speak to spoke to
nasalin because
we secured her release on furlough
we have been doing everything we can to
secure her release i know having spoken
to liz trust who's now foreign secretary
it's a top priority for her um and i my
heart goes out to that family and
ultimately
of course it is the iranian government
and they've got a new leadership a new
president uh i think widely regarded as
more hardline but nonetheless uh that's
what we have to deal with and it is
incumbent on them to release all of the
dual nationals and as included who are
arbitrarily detained and reunite them
with their loved ones give them the
money we owe them
well look in relation to uh the
so-called ims debt that's a historic
debt we've always said that we will work
to resolve that and that's outstanding
and those negotiations continue but i
don't think there can be any excuse for
arbitrarily detaining for the length of
time in the manner
and this isn't an isolated case there
are
other cases that we are working very
hard on and it's contrary to
international law and those uh nazi and
those other detainees should be released
and it's not just the uk
do you acknowledge though that if the
money is paid that we do it's accepted
that we do owe the iranians but dating
back to the 1970s then we will see the
dual nationals and brits being released
not clear to me at all and i don't think
there should be a direct quid pro quo
we've made clear that we want to resolve
that debt um but it's not being clear
that
the iranian government is seriously
committed to releasing uh all of our
dual nationals that's what needs to
happen would you ask him to end his
hunger strike in the meantime oh look
i've uh i've met richard and uh nassen
in i've spoken to nazdan i met all of
our detainees um i just want him safe
and well i've of course i don't give him
uh i try and tell him what to do in
terms of the tactics because he's the
one in the position of being
father and a husband to nazanin but i
want to see him safe and well so of
course i'd like to see him we've heard
his message we're doing everything we
can he knows me well i'm happy to speak
to him again but of course
he's speaking to liz trust as well but
what i would give him the assurance
which i hope would help is that we're
doing everything that we can okay um
deputy prime minister the speaker of the
house implored you and your colleagues
to sort out the mess that were in uh
yesterday he's talking about um a
corrupt sleazy group of politicians what
are you going to do which i think
lindsey hoyle the speaker make an
interesting intervention which is the
the committee on standards is looking at
the process the system um and i think
there should be cross-party uh support
for to get in a de-politicized way to
get the the system that we have in place
robust clear accountability clear
transparency but also fair in the sense
that there's a proper right of appeal
that anyone in any other
working professional life whether you as
a
journalist a doctor a nurse uh teacher
would expect and i think that's the way
you make a sustainable system we're very
committed to that it needs cross-party
support i think that's the point the
speaker was making yeah you also
conflated the two issues because you
thought you were going to get away with
that
i i don't thought we'd get away from it
but i do accept kay
just plainly it was a mistake to
conflate two issues one the case of that
individual npo in paterson who now of
course has resigned and secondly the
wider system for making sure you've got
due process it's a mistake i regret it
we as a government regret it should he
be made appear in the fullness of time
i'd look there's no question there's it
hasn't been offered there's absolutely
no question um of that uh being under
consideration so you wouldn't support it
well it's not something for me but i can
tell you it has not been offered and
there are no plans in relation to that
um of course the reason i brought that
up of course is because um 15 out of the
last 16 treasurers for the conservative
party have each donated at least uh
three million pounds not saying that as
a direct result they've got a seat in
the house of lords but nevertheless that
is the case the snp wants the
metropolitan police to look at it and
we've been speaking to labour this
morning and they support that i look
like
the they'll make their political points
in the way that they want to um but look
at what i would say is first of all
they're very clear rules for donations
to political parties no one's suggesting
any wrongdoing in regulation to to that
in this regard in relation to member
becoming appointed to the house of lords
there's also very clear rules i would
just say that of course people who are
entrepreneurs but also engaged in public
service whether that's charities whether
that's supporting political parties um
do a public service and uh and certainly
we benefit when the conservative party
is as a treasurer uh people who've got
that kind of experience
cash for peerages though is illegal well
and there's absolutely no question that
we haven't followed all of the rules in
relation to that and no one is
suggesting and i don't think you were
that we've done anything but the snp
says that they want the
metropolitan police to look at it is it
right that the police should look at it
if a political party two political
parties think they should okay of course
the independence of the police are
something that we all ought to respect
they shouldn't take
they shouldn't take instruction from any
political party um and they don't um and
there is no criminal investigation there
is no police investigation and frankly
there isn't a credible suggestion of any
wrongdoing in relation to this so it's
wasting police time
well that's something i think you could
meaningfully put to the s p and uh
modules and others
look i understand the the
the politics of this what i'm saying is
that the integrity and the rules have
been both in relation to house of lords
appointments and donations have been
very strictly followed there are very
clear rules and we follow them very
carefully okay let's go back to what was
happening in the house of commons
yesterday why was the pm not there
he was at a hospital in the northeast i
think as we come through this very
hemingway-esque he couldn't run any
further away could he well that was a i
think the thing is that was uh
a meeting a visit that was uh a
pre-existing commitment but i think
people would understand that as we come
back from the pandemic not just dealing
with the booster vaccine program which
is going great guns but we want to keep
pushing forward but also the backlog in
the nhs that we're funding uh uh to to
the tune of billions uh that that's
where his focus was but we also had the
senior member of the government in
cabinet the cabinet office minister
steve barkley who deals with this issue
uh responding at the house at the
dispatch box that's right too but he
could have you know there was time after
he got back into london he could have
gone to the um
to the chamber to at least show his face
and that would have been the right thing
to do according to some uh back bench
conservative mps you know they want the
captain on the pitch
well it's right to i think draw a team
analogy which is why you had steve
barkley as the responsible minister
looking at that dealing with that the
prime minister has already uh made a
statement uh on it but look uh and he
was dealing with uh he was on a visit to
the north east in a hospital uh i think
given the situation we've had with the
pandemic it's absolutely the right
priority why didn't he have his mask on
when he was in a clinical setting
well he followed all the advice and all
the guidance that he got
at all times and i think that's the
right thing for all of us to do yeah but
he should have had a mask on and you
know he's a busy man um it's a it's a
very challenging job do you think he
just forgot
i think like many of us we take the
advice uh and the guidance we've got in
in different settings and that's the
right thing for us to do as politicians
are the right thing for the public he
did say in clinical settings you should
wear a mask that's what he said
previously and everybody around him was
wearing a mask what what what impression
is that um for people who are looking to
their politicians to guide them well
look all i can say is when i go into a
setting just like the prime minister i
take the guidance that i'm given
particularly if you're on
an official visit and we follow that
very carefully and i think anyone
visiting would do that uh for whatever
the purpose of their visit was would you
wear a mask if you went into a hospital
i follow all the guidance very carefully
and when i go i was up visiting a prison
in
glen palva
last week uh when i go to the courts i
follow the advice the guidance that
we're given very carefully it was a
stupid thing for him to do
it i mean seriously he's in a hospital
he's surrounded by medics they've all
got flipping masks on and the prime
minister doesn't put one on he tucks his
tie and he rolls his sleeves up all he
had to do was put a mask on and instead
and then we wouldn't have been talking
about it now well i'm sure you'd have
found something else to figure i would
have but it wouldn't have been this okay
well um luke he followed the guidance
that was given to him and i think that's
the right thing to do um okay so as far
as the s p is concerned we feel that um
they are potentially um doing this in
order to make a political point you
would be very comfortable though if the
metropolitan police felt that it was
appropriate to at least look into the
situation like they did with labour with
uh when the pride when the then prime
minister tony blair was involved
look i'm saying i don't think it's right
for us to tell the police what to do the
police are independent that operational
dependence is crucially important and i
think frankly uh the sm
smp are just trying to rake muck
why do you say that
it's clearly the job in any society for
the police independently of political
persuasion influence or anything like
that to conduct their their their job
and it's for them to decide those
matters whether to launch an
investigation whether uh charges are
brought with the cps in relation to any
criminal case and they haven't done it
today and i think the s p calling for it
is clearly political but a complaint has
to be made in order for the police to
get involved doesn't it no the police
can get involved at their own initiative
in relation to uh any uh
crime or criminal offence they obviously
need um to have some investigative lead
but
they don't need a political party let
alone um the snp or any frankly any
other party telling them or directing
them or steering them with what to do
they don't need that to look at a case
lots of cases are uh backlogged um i
know that you spoke to tomorrow about it
uh yesterday and it and many many
thousands of cases need to be sorted out
um and and you didn't deny that it could
take eight or nine years to get back on
track well no look what i said is first
of all 95 criminal cases go through the
magistrates court the backlog there is
already coming down great tribute to
them and all the staff working there for
the five percent of cases that go
through the crown court which because of
social distancing meant jury trials
couldn't function in the in the usual
way i think people would understand that
we've had a backlog it's been rising
it's now stabilized and we're throwing
everything in to getting it down i'm
confident that within six to twelve
months we will get that we'll start
getting that backlogged down with the
super course that we're putting in place
to take multiple uh
uh defendants with the nightingale
courts with the extra money i secured
with the chancellor at the spending
review with the virtual technology with
removing the limit on sitting days and
we realize it's important it's not a
technical issue it's particularly
important for any victims who
have their cases pending and who want to
see justice done that's where
all of our efforts are going and where
are we as far as educating prisoners are
concerned going forward i think it's a
massive issue the three big things for
me uh um on top of building the places
so that dangerous offenders go into
prison um and increasing the sentencing
which we're doing with our police crime
uh sentencing a courts bill which labour
uh and the snp opposed it's important
that when people are in prison where
they get the drug rehabilitation they
get the skills and they can get some
training and if if possible get
employment i was just up at glen palva
i'm in leicestershire on the
state-of-the-art prisons that we're
building one of the things we're doing
is bringing in in-cell technology so
with simple things like uh numeracy and
literacy offenders are not just sitting
there in their bunk feet up but actually
focusing on getting themselves the
skills they need they can also then do
their theory a bit of their driving
license these are the kinds of things
that give them a chance to go straight
which is what cuts reoffending and
protects the public it could all be htv
drivers who knows by the time they come
out
of prison you guys are doing amazing
work in all sorts of areas i'm sure that
my viewers would agree with that but
they still keep coming back to this
sleaze nonsense you have to accept that
that you've got a credibility issue as a
government at the moment how are you
going to fix it the the the answer is to
have clear rules properly enforced and a
sustainable system um we you know i've
been very clear with you about the
handling uh and the conflation of the
case with the due process it was a
mistake we regret it um i think people
want to see us getting on with the job
and i do think we need a sustainable
system for complaints firm but fair
and that's what the public expect i
think they also want to see us getting
on with the job as you said making sure
our prisons work the prime minister out
making sure we're
at the hospital in the northeast making
sure we're dealing with a pandemic we
want to be dealing with that job and not
distracted by these issues and of course
you need a proper system in place to
make sure we can do that and a final
thought on the pandemic before i let you
go um double jabs
for those who are on the front line at
the nhs or they lose the job
look we the the health secretary will
announce more uh in relation to that
what do you think we've got a well i
think it's critically important in those
vulnerable settings care homes and the
nhs that particularly go through the
winter months that the vulnerable people
there are properly protected and i think
we need to get by any means necessary
those the level of jabs up we've done
well on the double jabs we've got uh and
the boosters we've got uh 10 million
across the country i think we've made
great strides in care homes and in the
nhs setting the overwhelming number of
people proportion of people in those
settings are now
jabbed but i think it's critically
important but for the welfare the
protection of the lives of those people
that are under their care so if you're
not double job then you really need to
not be working with the most vulnerable
well first and foremost at this stage
and the health sector will make any
further announcements we're just
encouraging everyone to come forward and
actually that process of encouragement
um has yielded great dividends but i
think people will understand
particularly in those most vulnerable
settings it is crucially important
everything we learn from the peak of the
of the crisis how important it is for
people to be insulated and protected
from the virus sounds like a yes
well as you're tempting me to preempt uh
any announcements in due course i'll
leave that to the health secretary but i
think we have made great progress and
the truth is going into these colder
months because of the vaccine rolled out
because of the measures we've taken
we're in a much more resilient place to
weather
these difficult months and come through
this and with the economy bounding uh
back with us getting the world together
at cop26 i think you get the feeling
that britain is bouncing back stronger
than before okay you had your booster
yet uh not yet but i'll come back
because you're not old enough i know
yeah yeah i had mine a month ago yeah
okay we'll leave it there then deputy
prime minister thanks so much adee for
joining us thanks a lot